president biden gives his inaugural
address biden unleashes his early policy
and the media realized they won't have
donald trump to kick around anymore i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
thousands of my listeners have already
secured their internet join them at
expressvpn.com
ben well inauguration day what an
auspicious day
for the country because it's the dawn of
a new era it's a magical new time
the celebration has begun and as i've
noted repeatedly i am not a big fan of
pomp and circumstance in american
government i really think that the
government is supposed to be sort of
like your plumber you call them when you
need them otherwise they should stay out
of your house
this idea that we're supposed to have
these sort of worshipful giant
ceremonies
not a fan okay have not been a fan for a
long time i used to say this about the
state of the union address whether it
was obama or whether it was trump
inauguration day is another one of those
and people treat it as though it's like
this massive
wonderful okay fine you want to do that
that's fine i'm not so into it to each
his own well the inauguration yesterday
was supposed to be very special
inauguration a magical inauguration
because the specter of orange man bad
was finally gone and a new day was
dawning the sun
was rising spackling the sky with colors
of gold and pink it was an incredible
incredible magical moment we're going to
get to joe biden's inaugural address in
just one second let it just be noted
that all of the talk that we've had
about unity over the past several months
from joe biden
it is very unclear whether by unity joe
biden means
that you should be respected in your
opinion and we should have
open and honest discussions and we
should leave each other alone or whether
by unity joe biden means i want you to
obey me and if you don't obey me i will
use the federal government to make you
obey me
so unity can be had in one of two ways
and he's been
rather vague about what he means by
unity so on today's show we're going to
explore what joe biden means
by unity what the left means by unity
because the real battle that joe biden
is going to have to fight if he wishes
to be a great president for all
americans as he says he does
is not a battle against the right it's
going to be a battle against the left
it's going to be a battle against his
own flank
which is demanding vengeance on people
who disagree censorship of people
who disagree control of all of the
institutions of power in the united
states
in order to make people who disagree
agree it will be unity through purge
if they have their way it'll be up to
joe biden to stand up to that
whether he does or not that remains an
open question i don't think it's going
to be open
for very long okay so yesterday featured
the swearing-in
of joe biden oddly enough he was
actually sworn in it was a coup he was
sworn in
actually 12 minutes early so it took
effect at noon he was sworn in like 1148
which was kind of weird anyway here was
joe biden being sworn in
as president of the united states
yesterday by chief justice john roberts
so a democrat swearing in the democrat
please raise your right hand and repeat
after me
i joseph robinette biden jr do solemnly
swear
hi joseph robinette biden jr do solemnly
that i will faithfully execute that i
will faithfully execute
the office of president of the united
states office of president of the united
states
and will to the best of my ability the
world for the best of my ability
preserve protect and defend preserve
protect
and defend the constitution of the
united states constitution of the united
states so help you god
so help me god congratulations mr
president
and we like all americans pray for the
success of the president when he
protects our rights and for his failure
when he does not protect our rights and
in fact invades those rights that should
be the same standard for all presidents
republican or democrat it is pretty
incredible on a personal level to see a
man who's been striving for the
presidency since he was 30 years old
finally achieved the presidency at the
at the age of 172. uh so that is that is
an amazing
accomplishment we have now learned over
the past several decades that pretty
much anybody can be president so long as
they stick around in politics
long enough joe biden is older than
every ex-president who attended his
inauguration
every single one right he is older than
bill clinton he's older than george w
bush he's significantly older than
barack obama so uh there's that
kamala harris was also sworn in and uh i
will say this was kind of hilarious so
sonia sotemayor who is the supreme court
justice very much on the left she swears
in
kamala harris and proceeds to botch her
name now i was informed
by our mainstream media that if you
botch kamala harris's name if you call
it kamala as opposed to kamala
that is a that is an element of racism
right they said this about tucker
carlson
they kept saying kamala ooh i guess
sonia sotomayor is racist now so here's
a racist swearing in kamalaris
i kamala davie harris do solemnly swear
i kamala davey harris i solemnly swear
that i will support and defend
the constitution of the united states
the constitution of united against all
enemies
against all enemies all right so that's
enough of that anyway
uh the celebrities were back in force
and that's going to be one of the more
obnoxious aspects of the
biden administration honestly it was
kind of a comfort to me that there was
not a lot of celebrity
outside celebrity involved in the trump
administration so trump himself was a
celebrity obviously
a very large scale celebrity entering
the oval office but
hollywood hated him tinseltown hated him
the music industry hated him
right every time he would play a song at
his rally the people who made the song
be like we don't want him using that
song anymore
and honestly i kind of found it
delightful that the celebrities were not
occupying the centers of power now we're
going to get the merger between
hollywood and dc that we had during the
obama years
it feels forced and awkward during the
biden administration because obama was
himself
a celebrity creation he had no extensive
legislative record
he was not a well-known politician when
he entered office he was more of a
celebrity than he was a politician
in truth i mean he's almost a messianic
figure to many people on the left
joe biden is none of those things he's
just a career politician kind of corrupt
old career politician and so having
hollywood can rush back in full force
is is pretty astonishing so lady gaga
showed up to sing the national anthem
dressed as a member of the cast from the
hunger games i'm not sure why she was
doing this also quick note uh the betsy
ross flag is okay again
remember when you had a whole
controversy like two years ago because
colin kaepernick that suggested
the betsy ross flag was racist
even though it had flown at the barack
obama inauguration while it was flying
again yesterday at the inauguration i
guess we don't have to worry about that
also the national anthem so
controversial that people should kneel
for it i guess we don't have to kneel
from the national anthem anymore so
that's exciting stuff
so here was uh lady gaga directly
from pan am singing the national anthem
[Music]
what is she wearing
there's a nice rendition of the national
anthem i was not as enamored with
jlo singing this land is your land which
is
indeed a comedy song um so she's saying
this land is your land we can stop that
uh j-lo saying this land is your land as
well as america the beautiful
and in the middle for no apparent reason
she just threw in let's get loud
so that was weird here's jlo doing that
[Music]
so frankly i'm now disappointed that
lady gaga did not throw in
a verse from telephone into the middle
of the national anthem
just in the middle of it
we may as well have had it and in a
second we're going to joe biden's actual
inaugural address which people are
praising to this guy's the greatest it's
the greatest speech anyone has given in
american history with the possible
exception
of the gettysburg address unbelievable
oratory sure it kind of sounded like
mashed potatoes and it was a bunch of
warmed over
pablum but it was a magical moment a
magical matchup
the entire media could take a deep
breath and go on vacation to tahiti just
drink their
cocktails and um get their massages and
that's gonna be the next four years so
if you've enjoyed the gaslighting of the
obama years welcome back we're gonna do
it
all over again super exciting stuff
first
let us talk about the fact that you need
a vpn i've been talking about expressvpn
on the show for months so why haven't
you just gotten a vpn just listen to me
ladies and gentlemen i will tell you
this
there has never been a more important
time to protect your digital rights
that's why i and thousands of my
patriotic listeners choose to secure our
online data
by using expressvpn did you believe a
vpn isn't for you because you can use
the internet just fine without one
anytime you go online your internet
service provider can see every single
site you're visiting
are you confused about how it works well
you shouldn't be expressvpn is an app
for computers and smartphones it
encrypts your network data reroutes it
through a secure server that means you
can use the internet more anonymously
without having your activity tracked
do you think vpns are complex only for
tech experts rongo they are not with
expressvpn you launch the app you tap
just one button to protect yourself it
really is that simple
i trust expressvpn to protect my online
data because they are rated number one
by cnet and wired and they stand for my
values now is the time for you
to take a stand take back your privacy
at expressvpn.com get three extra months
free
on that one year package again that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
to get three extra months for free visit
expressvpn.com
ben right now okay so all of that brings
us to the magical moment when joe biden
gets up
and he gives the inaugural address and
of course
what he said was fairly rote
but all of it was against the backdrop
of trump leaving and so because the
specter of trump has been built up to
such an extraordinary proportion
because trump was supposed to be this
gigantic threat to democracy
and because of january 6th which
actually was an insurrection attempt
a failed ridiculous insurrection attempt
but
an insurrection attempt nonetheless this
came against a backdrop of ugliness and
it made the speech
seem a little bit different than it
normally would have felt without that as
backdrop
so here was joe biden talking about this
being democracy's day
this is democracy's day a day of history
and hope
of renew and resolve through a crucible
for the ages america has been tested
anew
and america has risen to the challenge
today we celebrate the triumph not of a
candidate
but of a cause the cause of democracy
the people the will of the people
has been heard and the will of the
people has been heeded
we've learned again that democracy is
precious
democracy is fragile at this hour my
friends
democracy has prevailed okay well
actually democracy prevailed
before the inauguration democracy
prevailed when the electoral college did
its work democracy
prevailed when the states certified
their votes democracy prevailed when
vice president mike pence did his duty
under the constitution of the united
states and senator mitch mcconnell did
his duty under the constitution
of the united states as far as the
fragility of democracy there are a
couple of ways in which democracy is
fragile uh and
they don't all come from the right-wing
authoritarians who decided to storm the
capitol building
okay the the the threat to democracy
that is inherent in the invasion of your
individual rights that is very much on
the table
the militarization of all of the major
institutions in american society
against people who dissent that is very
much on the table
so if you think that democracy has
prevailed and will prevail forevermore
let me just note here that the
authoritarians are very much in control
of a lot of institutions
in our society in fact i will say that
if you are worried about the
threat to individual rights you should
be worried pretty deeply about the
backlash to january 6.
you can think that january 6 was
incredibly evil that the act of evil
that was perpetrated on january 6 was
disastrous
i think it was obviously you can also
say that the backlash which has involved
the attempt to de-platform
and to dismiss and to investigate people
who are not involved
to lump in everybody together to suggest
that everybody on the right was
like the capital rioters or incited the
capital riots and therefore we need to
crack down on all of that
that is indeed an extraordinarily large
threat to democracy
and a longer lasting threat to democracy
than a
bunch of moronic criminal yahoos going
into the capitol building
and uh and doing property damage and
threatening life
right so no the threat to democracy is
uh is certainly not over
and in fact maybe accelerating as we'll
get to in a second okay so
joe biden then suggests that he is going
to confront
crises that are facing the country the
way he defines crisis
every politician has to have a crisis
because if you have a crisis then you
can suggest some sort of outside
solution
it's the crisis that gives you power if
you're a politician if you're a
politician and you walk into office and
you say you know what
things are kind of okay everybody goes
okay leave us alone then but if you can
name a crisis
then you can take extraordinary powerful
action against that crisis so how you
define the crisis
is quite important to how you define the
solution to that crisis and what kind of
powers you believe you need in order to
solve
that crisis so here was joe biden
defining the crises that face the nation
we'll press forward with speed and
urgency for we have much to do
in this winter of peril and significant
possibilities
much to repair much to restore
much to heal much to build and much to
gain
a cry for racial justice some 400 years
in the making
moves us the dream of justice for all
will be deferred no longer a cry for
survival
comes from planet itself a cry that
can't be any more desperate
or any more clear and now a rise of
political extremism
white supremacy domestic terrorism
that we must confront and we will defeat
okay so let's talk about the crisis he's
mentioning here
so he started off with a couple of
crises that we kind of
skipped over here because they are real
crises and uncontroversial obviously
covet 19
and the economy which has been largely
shut down and that will require action
obviously now we'll get to his covenant
19 action which is basically lackluster
he has no plans to really elevate the
vaccine distribution system from what it
is
at least not very much okay but then he
has a few other crises he talks about he
says the cry for racial justice some 400
years in the making
moves us okay what does he mean by that
hey official discrimination in law was
made illegal in the 1960s
a private discrimination was made
illegal in the 1960s
it's been two generations since the
civil rights act of 1965.
so what is he talking about exactly the
cry for racial justice what is the
racial justice he's calling for the
answer of course
is that he is calling for a new
government-run regime
that sees any inequality as inequity
and sees any inequality as systemic in
nature that if
black people earn less than white people
that is definitely attributable to a
system and that means that the system of
the united states
must be changed and rights must be
violated individual rights must be
violated your economic rights your
freedom of association rights your
contractual rights all of those have to
be violated
by the federal government right that is
his crisis
okay so you might have looked at the
united states you might have said wow it
looks as though
black americans are earning more than
they ever have at least were up until
the pandemic
you might say that we now have a system
that bars discrimination
but according to joe biden the system
requires fundamental change and so he
has to pose the system
as a crisis right the system is the
crisis in joe biden's view
then he talks about the crisis of
climate change the planet itself crying
out now the planet itself is not crying
out the planet doesn't care about you
the plant doesn't care about me it's
just the planet that's it i mean it's
pretty great i'm a fan but
let's be real about this if the planet
warms the planet ain't gonna care
because it is not sentient
okay the question is how we are going to
deal with it and when you declare that
climate change is a crisis
this provides you with the impetus to be
able to basically do whatever you want
no matter how bad the policy is
one of the amazing things when you talk
to people who are left-wing
behind closed doors on climate change
they will fully acknowledge that
enormous amount of climate change is
already baked into the cake
that the best that we can do right now
is adaptation that mitigation is not
going to be the chief mechanism whereby
human beings deal with climate change
but when they go out in public then it's
like we should all stop flying planes
we should all stop using cars it's like
that none of that is effective
it really is not and then finally he
suggests
that he is going to fight the rise in
political extremism white supremacy and
domestic terrorism i'm going to confront
it and we're going to defeat it
and now on the surface this sounds
utterly uncontroversial who's a white
supremacist who likes those souls
right who likes those jackasses like who
no one
okay the white supremacists no one likes
them they are horrible horrible people
okay who likes domestic terrorists no
one go ahead and prosecute them they're
involved in criminal activity
political extremist now here's where we
start to get a little dicey are we
talking here
about folks who are you know conspiracy
theorists who believe dumb stuff
even if they do that's protected by the
first amendment but here is the thing
when joe biden says white supremacy he
doesn't actually mean
members of the kkk he doesn't actually
mean members of white supremacist groups
he means broadly writ what the left has
been claiming white supremacy means
which is any element of conservatism is
white supremacy if you voted for trump
it's because of white supremacy
if you believe that the government
should not be a fundamental part of your
life it's because of white supremacy
we've had full-on displays at the
national museum of african-american
history
that suggests that white supremacy is
the reason for people believing in the
meritocracy
we have colleges teaching people that
white supremacy is saying things like i
am colorblind and judge people on their
individual merit
white supremacy is anything and
everything that opposes the left's
agenda according to the left
right that's why they've been using the
term white supremacy because they
completely
ran out of steam with the term racist it
was thrown around so much that it lost
all meaning so now they've moved over
into white supremacy now normally what
white supremacy means is that you
believe as the term would suggest
that white people are superior to other
people right they are supreme white
supremacy
okay but not a lot of americans actually
believe that because it's dumb
and it's ridiculous so instead white
supremacy has been expanded
to include virtually everyone you don't
like everyone
is a white supremacist this is where
things start to get really dicey it's
why the definitions of words
matter and tucker carlson noticed this
noted this on a show last night he's
actually he's
exactly right this is not a matter of
semantics how you fill in the vessel
that is defined as white supremacy is
going to define
whether we remain a country or not
because if you're just saying
we are going to keep an eye on and
monitor people who
actually believe in a white ethno state
then first of all there's first
amendment protections for them but
at least you're targeting the right
ideology and the right people
right if however your idea of white
supremacy is disagrees with joe biden or
barack obama
then we have a bit of a problem and
here's the thing i think it's pretty
clear which way the left is moving on
this
i'll give you an example in just one
second okay a personal example in just
one second first
let us talk about your need for life
insurance so if you're a responsible
human being
you have to make sure that your family
is taken care of in case god forbid
something should happen to you
if getting life insurance is on your
to-do list for 2021 policy genius can
help you cross it off with ease policy
genius makes it easy for you to compare
more than 30 top insurers at once and
save over 50
in the process plus there's no hassle
because their licensed experts work for
you not the insurance companies here's
how it works first you head on over to
policygenius.com
in minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need and compare quotes
from top insurers to find your best
price
policy genius will then compare policies
starting at as little as one dollar a
day
you might even be eligible to skip that
in-person medical exam once you apply
the policy genius team will handle all
the paperwork and the red tape if you
hit any speed bumps during that
application process
they'll take care of everything for you
soup to nuts make this the year you
finally cross life insurance off your
list
get protection for your loved ones go to
policygenius.com and get started you
could say 50
or more by comparing quotes start the
new year with one less thing and to
worry about policy genius when it comes
to insurance it's nice
and extraordinarily important to get it
right make sure your family is protected
in case god forbid something happens to
you head on over to policy genius
you could say 50 or more by comparing
quotes policygenius.com okay so
here is an example of what the left
means when they say white supremacy they
don't actually mean white supremacy they
just mean you disagree
okay this is why when joe biden says
he's going to target white supremacy and
the rise of white supremacy
unless he's very clear that what he
means by the rise of white supremacy is
the rise of actual nazi groups
the rise of the kkk right the kind of
people the fbi arrested a white
supremacist
for planning to murder me and my family
not a couple of years ago right not a
fan
terrible terrible people but i don't
think that's what the left means here's
the evidence this is not what they mean
so karen attia over at the washington
post who is a truly egregiously bad
columnist
every single column is basically the
same and it's all about how america is
is racist and evil and bigoted and all
the rest right so she has a piece today
it is titled the media had a role to
play in the rise of trump it's time to
hold ourselves accountable
she says in his inaugural address biden
spoke about a rise of political
extremism white supremacy domestic
terrorism that we must confront and we
will defeat
the laudable frankness about the threat
of white supremacy surprised me but i
wish i could share his confidence about
confronting
and defeating it she says since the
capital siege of january 6
federal and local officials have been
scrambling to fortify washington and its
institutions against the threat of white
supremacy and violence but one national
institution remains painfully vulnerable
the mainstream media the breaches to our
fourth estate came long before january
6th of course
from the moment trump entered the 2016
race endless oxygen was given to his
racism and lies
white supremacists were teams worthy of
profiles noting their haircuts and
wardrobes or allowed npr air time to
rank the intelligence of the races
the breaches continued as ex-trump
officials were allowed to profit from
distorting the truth to the american
people
through tv analyst spots book deals and
harvard fellowships so she's saying that
at least
stephanik the republican congresswoman
from new york is a white supremacist
and if you had a tv analyst spot after
having worked in the trump
administration
that was white supremacy if he had a
book deal josh halley is a white
supremacist
our media ushered all this through the
door under the aegis of balance and
presenting both sides as karen atya of
the washington post
as if racism and white supremacy were
theoretical ideas to be debated not
life-threatening forces to be defeated
never would i have imagined that i would
say biden's stance on white supremacy is
more progressive than the media's
but here we are it took white blood
being spilled and elite lawmakers
being threatened for other sectors to
confront the need to forcefully guard
against
extremism in the wake of the capital
insurrection which left five dead
corporations pulled support from gop
politicians who supported the assault
okay
no gop politicians supported the assault
zero
you can't name them seriously
if you can name them they should be
prosecuted because that is a crime
several capital officials resigned
twitter kicked trump off its platform
apple and google removed parlor which
has increasingly become a haven for
extremism from their app stores
but says karanate here's where it gets
really good the media still seems
unwilling or unable to reform itself
there have been no major efforts as an
industry to systemically to
systematically examine the role we
played in america's journey to the brink
just this week the new york times
devoted a podcast episode to the
feelings of trump supporters see if you
actually
ask about what trump supporters are
feeling your devoting time to white
supremacy
barely a week after the siege politico
came under fire for allowing right-wing
personality ben shapiro
to guest write its popular playbook
newsletter despite his history of racist
and islamophobic statements
political editors defended platforming
shapiro by putting on the rusty armory
armor of both sidesism noting they
published msnbc's chris hayes as a voice
from the left
politico editor matt kaminski also said
mischief making has always been a part
of politico's secret sauce
after the past four years it was
startling to see a comment so in the
spirit of cbs chairman
leslie moonves's mercenary 2016
assessment of trump's campaign that it
may not be good for america but it's
damn good for cbs
has so little been learned media
coddling of those who attack racial and
religious minorities is not
mischief-making it is willful
moral malpractice i'm reminded that in
this country white people once gathered
to watch the public lynching of black
people and even made souvenir postcards
of the event i'm reminded that in
america
white racism against minorities is
titillating not disqualifying
because it is profitable and that is why
i worry america will find its
itself in this place again so this means
that we need to push uncompromising
anti-racism
we need to push everybody out of the
media who we don't like i mean this is
what she's saying
she literally is saying that because
politico had me write the playbook
because politico a political insider
website had me write the
not particularly well trafficked
playbook this was white supremacy
me literally the number one target of
white supremacists in 2016.
if you print a column by me you are now
complicit in white supremacy so
let me just say i have very little trust
that the left's definition of white
supremacy is limited to actual white
supremacists
by the way it's not just karanatya this
is a very commonly held perspective
on the left everything you don't like is
the outgrowth of white supremacy
and we've had people suggest the
national anthem is a white supremacist
anthem
we have had people suggest the american
flag stands for white supremacy
we've had people suggest over and over
and over again that if you voted for
trump
you in fact are in favor of white
supremacy
and if you think that the levers of
government are not going to be turned
against everyday americans
now let me present to you the actual
criminal john brenton who lied
when he was head of the cia he lied to
congress about monitoring their
communications
and here he was yesterday explaining
that intelligence is going to be
targeting white supremacy and then
listen to the way he describes white
supremacy
so i know looking forward that the
members of the the biden team
who have been nominated or have been
appointed
are now moving in laser-like fashion to
try to uncover as much they can about
what
looks very similar to insurgency
movements that we've seen overseas
where they germinate in different parts
of the country and they gain
strength and it brings together an
unholy alliance frequently
of religious religious extremists
authoritarians
fascists bigots racists nativists
even libertarians so just to be clear
the way he cobbled together that group
of people was religious extremists
authoritarians fascists biggest racist
nativists even libertarians
libertarians okay so i have a feeling
that you are using this term white
supremacy to just
mean anything i don't like which makes
perfect sense by the way because this is
actually what
ibrahim kendi who is kind of the
popularizer of all this nonsense
has said if you're a critical race
theorist like ibram kendi is
what you believe is that all of the
structures of america are inherently
white supremacist if you believe in the
1619 project
you believe that america is inherently a
white supremacist country and in order
to fight white supremacy you have to
fight against all those structures and
if you stand up for the structures if
you stand up for the constitution or the
declaration
if you stand up for individual rights
those are all just the
the superstructure of white supremacy
that must be defeated
so when joe biden says that he wants to
fight white supremacy does he mean that
he wants to go after you know the
richard spencers of the world
does he mean that he wants to go after
the unite the right rallies of the world
or does he mean that he just wants to go
after everybody who believes in the
constitution of the united states and
declaration of independence he's utterly
unclear on this the rest of the left is
not unclear this is why i say
joe biden's presidency is going to be
judged on whether he has the stones to
actually stand up to his own side which
has broadened the definition
of deplorable and awful out to include
everyone who disagrees
okay and then joe biden gets to his talk
about unity so back to his inaugural
address
he talks about unity and again i wish
that i had more faith when he talks
about unity what he actually meant was
unity of purpose in fighting things like
covet or unity of purpose in believing
in the individual rights guaranteed by
the constitution of the united states
but his left does not believe that not
in the slightest so here is joe biden
talking about unity
to overcome these challenges to restore
the soul and secure the future of
america
requires so much more than words
requires the most elusive of all things
in a democracy
unity unity
in another january on new year's day in
abraham lincoln signed the emancipation
proclamation
when he put pen to paper the president
said and i quote
if my name ever goes down into history
it'll be for this act and my whole
soul is in it
my whole soul is in it today
on this january day my whole soul is in
this
bringing america together uniting our
people
united in our nation and i ask every
american to join me
in this cause okay so
that all sounds really really nice right
i mean that sounds nice
yes all americans to join him in the
cause and it's gonna it's gonna be
it's gonna be wonderful we're gonna have
some unity okay but
let me just point out that once again
the unity that he is suggesting is a
unity
against right it's not just unity four
in favor of individual rights he never
says unity in favor of
acts he just has unity and it's unity
against people who are
racist nativist fear demonization okay
so how does he define those terms
i don't know you don't know either
that's kind of a problem
right clarity is what provides agreement
or disagreement
vagary provides dishonesty and this was
either a wonderful unifying speech or
highly dishonest and we're going to find
out in very short order
which one it was and if you say that i'm
being a little bit cynical about his
call for unity
that you know when he talks about unity
he really means it that we nee that he
he
understands that we can disagree maybe
you'll be right
maybe you'll be right but i think
there's a little bit of a reason for the
cynicism
okay so here he continued along these
lines he said politics doesn't have to
be a raging fire we can take the sting
out of politics
again i don't know if what he means by
this is basically cool your passions
because i'm in charge now
or i really want to hear your opinions
and we'll have a discussion then we'll
come to a
mutually agreeable exchange of ideas and
and find a conclusion
it is it's not clear to me which one of
these he means i think i have a few
indicators which i'll get to in just a
moment here was
joe biden yesterday i understand
that many of my fellow americans view
the future
with fear and trepidation but the answer
is not to turn inward
to retreat into competing factions
distrusting those who don't look like
look like you
or worship the way you do or don't get
their news from the same sources you do
we must end this uncivil war
that pits red against blue
rural versus ireland or rural versus
urban
conservative versus liberal we can do
this
if we open our souls instead of
hardening our hearts
sounds wonderful now flashback this is
2009 january 2009
a young politician inspirational
messianic figure named barack obama
takes office with an extraordinarily
high approval rating
and what does he do he immediately calls
for unity right i mean we have to get
some unity going here
so here's barack obama in 2009 using
exactly the same kind of terminology
as joe biden on this
day we gather because we have chosen
hope
over fear unity of purpose
over conflict and discord
on this day we come to proclaim an end
to the petty grievances
and false promises the recriminations
and worn out dogmas
that for far too long have strangled our
politics remember all the unity that
broke out right after that when he
started pushing enormous stimulus
packages a complete rewriting of the
american health care system and identity
politics remember that
so when people say unity i'm gonna need
some evidence that what you actually
mean
is real unity like the other americans
they're not your enemies
as opposed to shut the hell up and obey
right believe and obey also provides
unity just not the kind of unity that's
actually going to solve the problems the
country faces we'll get to more of this
in just one second because the media
we're just gaga over this not lady gaga
just gaga just
over the moon we'll get to this in one
second first let us talk about the fact
that you need to save money this year
okay the year is starting off on an
economic low note for a lot of people
you cannot afford to be spending all
this money
on a cell phone bill you don't have to
pay okay well when your family switches
to pure talk usa
from att verizon or t-mobile you could
save over 800 bucks a year that is real
money every single month right back in
your pocket you don't have to sacrifice
coverage
pure talk is on the same network as one
of those big carriers they charge you
half that's right no gimmicks
no fluff added to your bills which is
why pure talk is the top rated wireless
company by consumer affairs
how about this offer right now get
unlimited talk text six gigs of data for
just 30 bucks a month
and if you go over on data usage they're
not going to charge you for it grab that
mobile phone dial pal in 250 say
ben shapiro when you do you'll save 50
off your first month dial pound 2 5 0
say keyword ben shapiro that's pure talk
usa they are simply smarter wireless
right now you're overpaying because
you're paying for unlimited data that
you're not using instead
why not get unlimited talk text and six
gigs of data for 30 bucks a month and if
you go over
they're not going to charge you for it
head on over to pure talk usa right now
you'll say 50
off your first month when you dial pound
250 and say my name
ben shapiro that's pure talk usa simply
smarter
wireless okay so the media of course
we're just
drooling over this because they've been
waiting for four long years for donald
trump to go away
and this was going to be the restoration
now yes it's the restoration of the
pre-trump era
and the media have created this mythical
wonderful obama era in the same way
that jfk's administration was camelot
the obama era was
scandal-free the only bad thing that
ever happened is he wore a tan suit
everybody loved each other sure there
were race riots in 2016 and cops got
shot on the streets in dallas
and sure we had the slowest economic
recovery in a century but you know
everything was fantastic
under obama and now we get to return to
that magical time chris wallace
was just enamored of the speech he said
this is the best inaugural address
i have ever heard well
okay say three lines of it really
right now what was the most memorable
part of that speech
here is chris wallace we must
end this uncivil war and the way we can
do it is if we show each other a little
tolerance and humility
martha i thought it was a great speech
um i've been listening
to these inaugural addresses since 1961
john f kennedy asked not
i thought this was the best inaugural
address i ever heard
it was just wonderful because he said he
said we have to end this uncivil war and
then he proceeded to sign a bunch of
incredibly divisive executive orders
into law
and is he gonna hold that left in check
barack obama said exactly the same kind
of stuff as joe biden did yesterday
okay it did not end with america coming
together it ended with an
extraordinarily more divided
america which by the way resulted in the
election of donald trump okay the rest
of the media were even worse than
wallace
so cnn's john king he was like oh my god
it's like a breath of fresh air oh we
can all breathe again
we can all go on vacation because
they're just going to tell us the truth
we're not gonna have to
monitor them we're not gonna have this
trumpy crazy guy out there oh
oh it's just amazing it's like breathing
fresh air ah
john king president bush is happy today
to be there as a republican
even mitch mcconnell who was with
president trump for most of the last
four years
in recent days has made it pretty clear
he wants to shove president trump to the
sidelines if he can to be part
of the republicans trying to do that and
so
there's a cleansing is a an error of
cleansing about today
uh there's an internal fight in the
republican party about president trump
soon to be former president trump that's
going to continue okay meanwhile the new
york times headline okay headline this
morning
whether or not related to the former
president's absence a bipartisan
lightness seemed to prevail across the
stage at president joe biden's
inauguration
snow flurries gave way to sun i'm not
kidding that's actually a headline
in the new york times snow flurries gave
way to sun you see the universe itself
was smiling on joe biden the weather
itself reflected
the joy felt by all including god
himself
at joe biden's ascension to power what a
magical
moment ah it's like ralph waldo emerson
speaking
about how nature reflects us it's
transcendental
oh incredible here's cnn's van jones
saying that that this was just it was
medicine in the wounds
he's going to bind us allah it's going
to be oh
everything's healed guys it's all over
america fixed
all your problems over by the way
yesterday was the single greatest covet
death day
of the entire time in america and joe
biden said yesterday
that um they're downplaying their
expectations for vaccine distribution
all that but
stop that it was amazeballs everything
is gonna from here on in
it's just gravy city it's gonna be
unbelievable here was uh van jones
he spoke from the depth of his soul and
we needed this and
you know that was beautiful you know
beauty heals
beauty heals there was not one part of
that that wasn't just
medicine in the wound and if you have
any doubt
that one person can make a difference
that one person's voice one person's
commitment one person's
you know bedrock faith can be the the
pivot point
for a nation just watch that speech
again and look at look at how the
country responds
i mean there's one man who can make a
difference it is this
geriatric old corrupt politician from
delaware who's going to bring us
together now listen
i hope he does i hope that what he means
by unity is actual unity
i have serious serious doubts again the
media coverage here is just
astonishingly ridiculous so my favorite
here
is um the tweets from the celebrities
the tweets from the celebrities are
always the best because
when i need a little bit of edification
i go to extraordinarily rich and famous
people explaining
to me why we need elites running our
lives
oprah winfrey tweeted out decency and
compassion restored hallelujah
president joe biden yes
great reese witherspoon tweeted out what
an incredible moment for us all to
witness i i know it was like
like the birth of my child frankly was
watching this old daughtering guy take
office
while the division in our country is
still painfully real i'm optimistic this
is a moment of recommitment to each
other a commitment to becoming a united
states again today i feel hopeful for
the future of our nation i'm sure you do
now let me just say this if a republican
had taken office and uh and then given
that exact same speech like a not trump
republican had taken office and given
that exact same speech
uh they would not be saying any of this
george w bush that kind of stuff all the
time
left hated him jimmy kimmel who's just a
an activist masquerading as a comedian
say congratulations to our new president
joe biden and vp kamal harris we know
you will do your best to make america
good again wow oh
it warms the cockles of your heart
doesn't it and then we've got
kerry washington again all these are
democratic activists so much work to do
but today i want to celebrate and pray
and revel in our tremendous power even
against all odds to make history happen
yeah that's the part they care about
right
it's the tremendous power unlimited
power
and this one was my favorite personally
this is mindy kaling an extraordinarily
rich
famous talented and powerful woman
tweeting out a picture of her daughter
watching the inauguration
of kamala harris and saying it matters
happy inauguration you know what
honestly until until mindy kaling's
daughter
saw kamala harris become vice president
she'd never known that women could be
powerful and rich except for her mother
who's extremely powerful and rich
i mean she needed to see kamala harris
on tv it was it was very very important
i hate this kind of crap i hate it with
a passion
yeah i've never said to my i have two
daughters
i will never say to them look at that
politician until you saw that politician
didn't you believe
that you were limited but now you see
they never would have said that if sarah
palin had been elected vice president in
2008 obviously
okay so in a second we are going to be
getting to the unifying actions right so
it's the actions that matter the
unifying actions
of joe biden how unifying are they and
the answer is
nope he's just a typical democratic
politician he's going to be incredibly
divisive
he's going to go too far in his policy
and he'll try and suggest that his
attitude makes up for all of it i hope
that he has a better attitude than
his predecessors but you know what that
ain't gonna make up for the fact that if
you
drive dramatically top-down policy unity
ain't in the offing
we'll get to more of this in just one
second first let us talk about the
underwear that grace your tuchus when
you start every morning in tommy john
underwear you are that much more
comfortable you can do everything better
trade out whatever cheap underwear was
sliding down and riding up last year for
tommy john
you can finally get the comfort you
deserve with dozens of comfort
innovations once you've tried tommy john
underwear you're never going back that's
why tommy john doesn't have customers
they have fanatics
what kind of innovations are we talking
about well they've got these breathable
lightweight moisture wicking fabrics
four times the stretch of competing
brands so it moves with you not against
you tommy john underwear comes with a
non-rolling waistband for the perfect
fit the legs never ride up
each of tommy john's 13 million pairs of
underwear sold are covered by a no
wedgie
guarantee which definitely would help me
in high school i am wearing
tommy john underwear right now and they
are just wonderful they grant me the
comfort level politics
does not there's no risk with tommy
john's best pair you'll ever wear or
it's free guarantee try
tommy john today if you don't love them
they are free go to tommyjohn.com
ben save 15 on your first order go right
now say 15
right now at tommyjohn.com ben again
that is tommyjohn.com
slash ben go check them out right now
tommyjohn.com to say 15
on your first order you can see the site
for details
oh if you haven't heard about it yet
daily wires in the entertainment game
last week we released our first film run
hide fight exclusively for daily wire
members you can catch it at
dailywire.com on our mobile app on our
streaming apps at apple tv and roku if
you're not a daily wire member yet use
promo code rhf to get 25
off to watch it if you want to compete
in the culture and help us compete in
the culture we need your help we need
your membership we picked up run hide
fight after hollywood studios turned it
down because it was quote unquote
distasteful hollywood didn't like the
film because it is not a leftist talking
points film
it wasn't pro gun control and it
celebrates bravery run hide fight
follows a 17 year old girl named zoe
who's just trying to get through the
last days of high school when she has to
face down
a bunch of evil school shooters
reviewers are saying things like well i
found this film considerably less
distasteful than i imagined i might
going in
it's still being released by some
despicable people the film's underlying
themes are gross
that said more entertaining than one
might assume that'd be dominant griffin
again these are left-wing critics
jessica king at literally no point in
this weirdly lumbering sluggish movie's
narrative that is grotesque
tastelessness ever appear to have
occurred to anyone involved
the critics hate it they hate it so the
critics
despise the thing um but you love it
almost 2 000 new audience reviews have
come in since they opened the comments
the audience scored is currently 92 on
rotten tomatoes you the audience you're
the people we care about
we make stuff and we bring stuff to you
that critics hate and that you love
we hope you'll join us and become a
member today over at dailywire.com
remember you'll get 25
off when you use promo code rhf go watch
the movie if you like it leave a review
this is the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in radio show in
the nation
[Music]
so we were promised unity right unity
well the media who love unity right they
love it
into it super into unity want unity
because joe biden wants unity and we
know it's gonna be a very unifying time
full of unitying
now here's nicole wallace on msnbc
suggesting that republicans should just
be banned
it would be my policy that a republican
must assert the truth before they're
allowed to share
any other views and lindsey graham i
understand appeared somewhere today and
refused to
really go far enough in beating down the
lie
if we can protect against counterfeit
dollar bills we should be able to
protect against fake news
that we now know has the potential to
kill people
as it did two weeks ago oh so we're
going to crack down on fake news are we
oh that's unitying you see there's a
first amendment here but we need to
crack down on fake news then
she brings on ben rhodes who was a
damned liar ben rhodes was the worst
liar in an administration full of them
ben rhodes the fiction writer made
national security
adviser to to barack obama overtly
admitted that he lied to an echo chamber
of people about the iran nuclear deal
and used them as his propaganda tools
and here he was
explaining that in order to in order to
protect national security we have to
detox
lies and hate i mean the gaslighting
over the next four years is gonna be so
strong it's gonna be it's gonna drive
you up a wall that's why you should
listen to the show because we're going
to
remind you that you're not the crazy one
some of these folks are the crazy people
here is ben rhodes again absolute liar
awful human being suggesting that
national security
must be must be upheld by quote-unquote
detoxing the lies and hey this doesn't
sound authoritarian at all
there's a broader societal issue that
it's going to take many years
to detox the disinformation the lies
the hate that has been spread a whole
segment of the american population has
been radicalized
by what has happened over the last four
years and by the fact that donald trump
is no longer there
they can no longer see donald trump kind
of representing their grievances in the
highest office
and so those grievances are going to go
back underground
uh and i think there's a lot of work to
be done to deal with the broader
societal issues
that go beyond what even national
security homeland security professionals
could do
amazing i mean i i need to hear about
truth and lies
from from this schmuck and perfect just
just need to hear about that all the
time by the way the media were very much
in love with jen saki jen sackey was a
liar
for the state department under obama she
is now the chief liar for as press
secretary
for joe biden and listen i don't
begrudge her the fact that she is a
professional
liar i mean this is what press
secretaries do okay robert gibbs is a
liar jay carney was a liar
the the bush administration press
secretaries were actually fairly honest
but
the the obama ones were certainly not
they used to lie routinely
and well now she's it she was obviously
in obama
states but i mean she literally admitted
to lying to the media
while she was in the state department
for barack obama now she's the white
house press secretary for joe
biden and she immediately just starts
being asked softball questions in the
media are like she's an amazing press
secretary
so yesterday in her first press
conference
she was asked questions like this one
get ready for this hard hitting
reporting you ready here we go
will he keep donald trump's air force
one color scheme change
this is such a good question i have not
had the opportunity to dig into that
today
given the number of executive actions
orders the inauguration
a few things happening um i will venture
to get you an answer on that and maybe
we can talk about it in here tomorrow
it is such a good question guys is he
going to change
the the furniture arrangement in the
oval office he did
it was a big story did he put up a bust
of mlk and you put up another one of
caesar chavez by the way opposing
illegal immigration whoops
okay but i mean those are hard-hitting
reporting right there by the way the
media
put out stories today about how jen
saki's first press conference was filled
with honesty
she said two overtly false things in the
middle of the press conference first
she suggested that joe biden was rolling
back the so-called muslim ban there is
not a muslim ban
muslims have been entering the united
states throughout the uh throughout the
trump administration
there is a ban on immigrants from
particular countries some of which were
muslim and some of which were not okay
so that's an overt lie
over lie number two she's asked
specifically about joe biden's position
on the hyde amendment
and she says i don't have any
information on that right now but he's a
he's a catholic and your catholics are
pretty pro-life
thank you for not giving us an answer to
anything there and the media just
clapping like seals
get ready for this we're gonna get years
on end of this years on end
and remember joe biden he is in favor of
norms
he doesn't violate norms in any way well
one of his first moves
is firing a labor arbiter okay so this
is according to the washington free
beacon
bill mcmorris reporting president joe
biden fired an independent federal labor
regulator within hours of taking office
on wednesday in an
unprecedented move that was cheered by
labor unions within minutes of his
inauguration
biden threatened to fire national labor
relations board general counsel peter
robb
if he did not voluntarily resign his
position as top prosecutor at the agency
rob whose four-year term was set to
expire in november rebuked biden's
demand
saying it would undermine the
independence of the agency and the
enforcement of federal labor law
it was my understanding the incoming
administration intended to foster
civility and unity in this country
and in the governing of this country
promising to adhere to the rule of law
and enabling its chief
law enforcement officers the
independence free from white house
interference to enforce the laws of the
united states said rob
a presidential removal of the nlrb's
general counsel prior to the expiration
of his or her term
violates these promises and principles
well yeah but it doesn't matter because
you see
biden's doing it if if donald trump came
in and he fired a bunch of people like
preet bharara
it was the end of the world end of the
world unprecedented unbelievable even
though
it is pretty precedented for presidents
to come in and then
clear out the doj but here you have a
really unprecedented act you have an
independent
an independent general counsel appointed
by law to a term that ends in november
and he's being fired right off the bat
media can't be bothered with it doesn't
matter
because unity is happening guys unity is
breaking out all over just
all over the place insane levels of
unity
great great stuff okay so in just a
second
i want to get to some of joe biden's
initial actions because the unity is not
there okay there is the
for for a guy who's pushing unity let's
talk about um
joe biden's first day executive actions
she has a bunch of them
there were 17 executive moves that joe
biden made just hours after his
inauguration
some of these were relatively
uncontroversial right some of them were
memos and directives to agencies
he said i'm going to start by keeping
the promises i made to the american
people what were those promises well he
halted
all funding for the construction of the
border wall he reversed the travel ban
targeting largely muslim countries okay
largely muslim
mean some are muslim and some are not so
presumably we're now going to just
start bringing in people from countries
where he actually can't verify who these
folks are
and then of course he rejoined the who
which is a chinese cat's paw
he also imposed a mask mandate on
federal property which is exciting
he then proceeded to violate that mass
mandate by going on to federal property
without a mouse so that was that was
pretty cool
i enjoyed that a lot other things that
he did
right off the bat well let's see
he first of all he's a bunch of themed
days it's super exciting there's a bunch
of themed days we'll get to those in a
second over the next few days i need
themes
like frankly i loved infrastructure week
so much that i need like infrastructure
day
equity day we're going to get all of
those so what exactly are the uh are the
executive orders so according to cnn
there were
17 of them nine of them were directly
reversing
things that donald trump had done
he extended an existing nationwide
moratorium on evictions and foreclosures
he extended the pause on student loan
payments all of which was fine for the
moment
he rejoined the paris climate accord
which should be a treaty and should be
submitted to the senate as a treaty but
captain constitution over here he's
perfectly happy with joining all of
these non-binding agreements
and pretending that they are not in fact
treaties he cancelled the keystone xl
pipeline
which even pissed off justin trudeau
right handsome bernie up north
he was like this is really bad like
that's that's a good way for us to
remain competitive on the world markets
also he rescinded the trump
administration's 1776 commission and
directed agencies to review their
actions to ensure racial equity oh goody
goody gumdrops
remember that big fight we had this year
over whether critical race theory should
be taught inside america's government
well now now it's going to be they're
going to just go right back to teaching
1619 propaganda about how america's evil
and terrible
and white supremacist and how the only
way to fight white supremacy is by
changing the structure of the system and
how government is the only
body capable of changing those
underlying evil structures he's going to
do that
he also signed an executive order
preventing workplace discrimination on
the basis of sexual orientation or
gender identity so that'll be
exciting as he applies that to all sorts
of federal contractors who wish to
uphold their own religious
uh or and or factual values by the way
when you're talking about
you know basically mandating
that all sorts of government-sponsored
or government-funded agencies
now have to go along with radical gender
ideology you know what that means by the
way
so abigail schreier points out on day
one by unilaterally eviscerates women's
sports any educational institution that
receives federal funding must admit
biologically male athletes to women's
team women's scholarships etc
a new glass ceiling was just placed over
girls so that sounds unifying to me
right is that we are now going to be
essentially forcing
all sorts of women's only groups to
allow in men who believe they are women
including in sports
he's going to change the census
requiring non-citizens to be included in
the census and apportionment of
congressional representatives of course
he wants to do this so the idea here is
you're going to maximize the number of
illegal immigrants who enter the united
states then you're going to count them
in the census and they're all going to
centralize because they
tend to in heavily blue areas where
benefits are given
and then we're just going to apportion
more congressional seats on the basis of
people who can't legally vote because
they're not in the country legally
so that is the thing that he is doing he
is also going to be
undoing trump's expansion of immigration
enforcement within the united states
we're going to stop enforcing the law on
immigration
he's also going to direct the omb
director to develop recommendations to
modernize the regulatory review and
undoing trump's regulatory approval
process so he's going to make it easier
to issue
recommend recommended regulatory
restrictions
so all of this sounds super unifying to
me does it not i mean this this is
really really unifying stuff
very exciting in other news joe biden
has announced that they are worried
that the virus is spinning out of
control so remember five minutes ago
before he was president of the united
states
it was i'm gonna come in here and i'm
gonna quash the virus remember he says
i'm not going to crush you
i'm not going to crush the economy i'm
going to crush the virus so that was out
the window in literally the first five
minutes of the administration
according to bloomberg president joe
biden's team is increasingly worried the
coronavirus pandemic is spiraling out of
control
imperiling has promised to contain the
outbreak as cases in death's mount
vaccinations lag and a more
transmissible strain emerges in the u.s
according to people familiar with the
matter
love how the media is just lowering
expectations for sleepy old joe here
that's great
as they learn more about the federal
response to the pandemic biden's
transition team grew alarmed
at a lack of coordination with states
the people said oh we're gonna just
blame it on the guy before
what a novel strategy i've never heard
anything like it
biden himself has warned of a dark
winter and has flatly said the pandemic
will worsen
before it improves the stakes are
escalating u.s hospitalizations are at
near
record levels of course the washington
post by the way
they have an excellent newsletter they
put out called the health 202.
um paige cunningham writes it and here
is their headline today
biden's just released coronavirus
strategy keeps vaccine goals modest
by this paige cunningham presumably
means that he's not actually going to do
all that much that is different from
what is actually being done
his aim 100 million shots administered
in the next 100 days would require a
roughly 25
ramp up from the current daily rate
which is hovering about 800 000 shots
administered each day
that daily rate achieved in the final
days of the trump administration has
remained flat over the past few days but
is more than double what it was
two weeks ago so we've doubled it in two
weeks and biden's gonna be like well you
know what we'll like shoot like slightly
higher than that and then that's about
it
biden seems to be taking an under
promise and over deliver approach after
his predecessor repeatedly made
unrealistic promises
about immunizations that did not
transpire
at least paige cunningham is reporting
that honestly that's pretty obviously
what they're doing here
they're they're putting together a plan
that supposedly does not actually help
things all that much and then they're
gonna claim when they exceed the plan
look how wonderful we are typical
political thing and not not rare
doesn't matter biden's team is saying
it's so ambitious jeffrey zentz white
house pandemic response coordinator says
it's a much faster pace than the current
pace so much faster he says it's just
the start we believe the comprehensive
strategy we've outlined
will get the job done yeah i'm sure i'm
sure
okay so meanwhile by the way amazon if
you believe that corporate america is
not in the tank for the democrats they
are so
in the tank for the democrats it's
insane how in the tank for the democrats
they are so remember
how like one week after the election
took place remember like one week later
pfizer was like hey guess what we have a
working vaccine and remember
how literally three weeks before they
knew they had a working vaccine and then
they just didn't announce it
that was fun well now amazon literally
the day that biden takes office amazon
goes to joe biden they're like you know
what we can help you deliver vaccine
you know what have been helpful amazon
considering how much money you have made
off of this pandemic and the fact that
everybody
and i'm a big amazon fan right i use
amazon i'm an original amazon prime
member
you know i've been really helpful as
people were dying of covet over the last
couple of months and we've been having
vaccine
distribution problems if you had come
around say
right after the approval of the vaccines
and said to the trump administration
which was
already outgoing it was after the
election hey guys we would love to help
distribute the vaccine but you didn't
instead you waited till literally the
day that joe biden took office and
magically
just day of days it's incredible truly
incredible
today amazon has now offered its help
according to nbc news amazon has
extended an offer to president joe biden
to assist with the national distribution
of covet 19 vaccines
a move that could expedite the federal
effort to combat the pandemic dave clark
ceo of amazon's consumer business one of
the company's highest ranking executives
sent a letter to the president shortly
after he was sworn in wednesday
he said as you begin your work leading
the country out of the coven 19 crisis
amazon stands ready to assist you in
reaching your goal of vaccinating 100
million americans in the first 100 days
of your administration
we are prepared to leverage our
operations i.t and communications
capabilities
and expertise to assist your
administration's vaccination efforts
our scale allows us to make a meaningful
impact immediately in the fight against
coveted in 19 we stand ready to assist
you
in this effort wow you know what have
been really great is if you had um
not been politically driven jerks and
actually done that
you know like before biden took office
that'd been really solid stuff
i'm sensing all of the unification and
the coming together right here i mean
honestly it's very very strong
speaking of which joe biden's
immigration priorities are very much
open
and they are transformational byron york
has a piece of the washington examiner
talking about it
he says the new biden administration
says it must act quickly with a flurry
of executive orders because the nation
is experiencing
not one not two not three but four
crises so
president biden should undo much of what
trump did as quickly as possible
of biden's 17 actions three dealt with
corona virus two dealt with the economy
two dealt with climate two with racial
equity one with the census
one with ethics one with regulation and
five with immigration
five with immigration so it is pretty
clear the top priority here is
immigration
it is perhaps the top issue for the
democratic base says byron york from
grassroots organizers to big tech
billionaires and so it is the top issue
for the new democratic president
during the democratic presidential
primary debate biden refused to advocate
a deportation freeze
instead defending the obama
administration's deportation policy but
he came under heavy pressure from
hispanic activist groups and then
changed
his position he said in a march 2020
debate the first hundred days of my
administration no one
no one will be deported at all
so the current process has now stopped
cold apparently
biden's order says the us can deport an
illegal immigrant if there is a written
finding by the director of ice that the
immigrant had endangered
had engaged in or since or is suspected
of terrorism or espionage or poses a
danger to the national security
of the united states and ice can deport
people who have arrived
in the united states since november 1st
which means the election
but those are options and biden doesn't
have to exercise them and again he has
promised he's not going to deport anyone
in the first hundred days
so all of this is uh i think greatly
unifying you can feel the unity breaking
out
all over this is not going to be just
biden exercising power from the
executive branch in defiance of
constitutional mandate
it is not joe biden just ignoring one
half of the country to push forward a
bunch of lefty causes
to the clapping seal seal claps of the
media
it's not gonna be any of that it's gonna
be unity guys it's gonna be discussion
and unity
and wonder can you feel all of it
breaking out can you feel all of it
breaking out right now
oh you can't because you think that it's
mainly a bunch of
pablum and talk yeah i'm getting that
indicator too i'm getting that indicator
too alrighty we'll be back here today
with one additional hour of content also
coming up soon is the matte wall show it
is
1 30 pm eastern today that is breaking
down his take on why a patriot party
is a bad bad idea be sure to check it
out over at dailywire.com
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel wydowsky our
associate producers are rebecca doyle
and savannah dominguez the show is
edited by adam scievents
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright 2021
on the matt well show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics
but culture faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show